sasha thank you doctors dropping
coverage in accounts being sent to
collections those are a couple of the
issues ccsd teachers say they're dealing
with right now because their health
insurance is not paying up tonight tht
health says they're trying to make
progress orco man alive after hearing
from all sides tonight
brian the ccsc school board meeting is
still going on tonight thc health says
it's committed to helping ccsd educators
but teachers tell us that they're so fed
up with their unpaid medical bills they
want proof of the progress
[Music]
ccsd teachers frustrated with their
health care headache rally outside
thursday night's school board meeting i
have one that's eighteen hundred dollars
that they owe out teachers say they're
being mailed bills because thc health is
not paying up i have to pass by my
mailbox with just dread of what today's
notice is gonna be that's not fair some
say doctors are now dropping them it's
very scary to me like oh i can't get
sick i can't i gotta take care of my
teeth i gotta make sure i'm good we are
in a dire situation this is unacceptable
educators pleading with the school board
and tht health to fix the problems this
is a heavy lift for sure the new ceo of
thc health saying under him things will
change we have the ability to influence
this market but we have to have credible
leadership at the top and drive that
forward tht health is dealing with a
roughly 40 million deficit this
financial year they've reduced staff to
pump more money into the system in may
ccsd provided an advance of 35 million
dollars but the teachers union says the
district needs to do more to help we're
going to still run into a deficit every
month without a contribution from the
district ccsd pushing back is tht's
financial responsibility teachers say
enough finger pointing they just want
their bills paid we shouldn't have to
ask for this
tonight's meeting is just a presentation
and no action is being taken reporting
live in las vegas tonight orc omana live
local now